In the morning, a teenager wakes up and uses facial recognition...
...to unlock her phone.
She scrolls through social media feeds to see what's new.
Then, she asks the voice assistant on her phone...
...what the weather's going to be like that day....
...so she knows how to dress for school.
A college student uses an app on his phone...
...to deposit a birthday check from his grandmother.
He takes a photo of the check,...
...and the app automatically reads the handwriting...
...to figure out the amount.
It then deposits in into his account.
Meanwhile, a younger student uses a different app...
...that is teaching her a new language.
The app listens to what she says...
...and can recognize what she's saying even if she makes mistakes.
The app then gives her personalized feedback on her pronunciation.